in this video we're going to talk about
interior and exterior angles and
polygons some which are regular polygons
some which are not regular polygons and
we're going to go through the formulas
that are involved with solving these
problems we're gonna go through six
examples and let's start off by talking
about some of the formulas first so if
you want to find the sum of all the
interior angles all the angles on the
inside of a polygon use this formula
here n minus 2 times 180 so n represents
the number of sides or the number of
angles those are gonna be the same and
you just have to subtract 2 and then
multiply by 180 and that gives you the
total of all those interior angles
whereas with the exterior angles these
are the angles that are on the outside
of the polygon all those angles are
always going to add up to 360 degrees no
matter whether it's a regular polygon or
not a regular polygon the exterior
angles always add up to 360 now when you
look at a polygon just to show you real
quick let's say this is your polygon and
each of vertex if you were just extend
one of the sides that angle there is an
exterior angle same thing here if I was
to extend either this side or this side
either one that's an exterior angle so
you have one exterior angle at each
vertex or at each corner if you will of
the polygon so all those angles would
add up to 360 this formula here is the
same as this formula here you can notice
but we're dividing by N and this is how
you'd find the measure of just one
interior angle in a regular polygon now
remember with regular polygons all the
angles are the same all the sides are
the same and this last one here 360 just
like this form that all the exterior
angles add up to 360 but if it's a
regular polygon by dividing by the
number of exterior angles or by the
number of sides they're gonna be the
same you can find out the measure of
just one of those exterior angles so
let's go ahead and dive into some of
these examples number one how would you
find out what these angles are right
here well you can see they are the same
they're both acts well the first thing
we have to figure out is are these
interior angles or are the exterior
angles well you can see they're on the
inside their interior and we know that
all these angles are going to
add up to n minus 2 times 180 well we've
got 1 2 3 4 5 angles so it's going to be
5 minus 2 times 180 degrees so that's
gonna be 3 times 180 which is 540
degrees total so if we add these up 90
plus 150 plus 90 plus X plus X that has
to equal 540 and we can write an
equation so let's go ahead and do that
let's see 90 plus 90 is 180 plus 100 is
280 plus 50 is 330
so that's 330 plus 2ax
equals the total of interior angles 540
if we subtract 330 from both sides we
get 210 equals 2x and if we divide both
sides by 2 we get x equals a hundred and
five degrees and that's the measure of
both of these angles okay let's go to
number two now so for number two what we
have is we have see these marks here all
these sides are congruent this is a
regular hexagon because there's six
sides six angles all the angles are the
same measure all the sides are the same
length but we want to do is we want to
find out what the exterior angle measure
is and what the interior angle measure
is so let's go ahead and find the
exterior angle first we know all the
exterior angles add up to 360 but if we
divide by how many we have which in this
case is going to be 6 we get 60 degrees
so that's the measure of just this
exterior angle here 60 now to find the
interior angle you can see how this
forms a straight line right here so if
this saying will 60 this angle on the
inside must be 180 minus 60 they form a
linear pair so that means that Y is
going to equal 120 degrees now the other
way to do it is to use this formula
right here and we can say n minus 2 so
that would be 6 minus 2
since there's six angles here times 180
so that gives us 720 so that's the sum
of all the interior angles but then
we're dividing by the sixth interior
angles so 720 divided by 6 equals 120
thinking we got here so sometimes it's
easier to use this formula and then just
subtract from 180 to find the interior
angle just a little bit quicker for
number three now what do you think for
this one well it looks like we're given
the exterior angles here and we know
that all those exterior angles add up to
360 now this is not a regular polygon
all the sides and all the angles are not
the same but they always add up to 360
so let's just make an equation here 90
plus 90 is 180 plus 150 is 330 plus x
equals 360 degrees so if we subtract 330
from both sides you can see that ax this
missing angle here would be a 30 degree
angle okay number four five and six
these are like word problems see if you
can do these on your own and we'll go
through them number four says name the
regular polygon with interior angles
that sum to two thousand eight hundred
and eighty degrees okay so basically
they're telling us all those angles on
the inside of the polygon add up to 2880
so we want to use this formula right
here it's going to be n minus two times
180 equals the total the interior angles
which they tell us is two thousand eight
hundred and eighty degrees so you can do
this a couple different ways you could
distribute the 180 like this or you can
divide both sides by 180
I'll just distribute so this is 180 n
minus 360 equals two thousand eight
hundred and eighty if we add 360 to both
sides that gives us a hundred and eighty
n equals let's do this on the calculator
to eight eight zero plus 360 so that's
32 40 and if we divide both sides by 180
that comes out to 18 so that means this
is an 18 gone okay meaning it has 18
angles or 18 sides and it's a regular 18
guy okay for number five now it says
mean the regular polygon so another
regular one that has an exterior angle
of 30 degrees okay so let's use this
formula over here if we want to find
them
just one exterior angle it comes out to
360 divided by n equals the measure of
that exterior angle which in this case
they tell us is 30 degrees so what we
can do here is we can think of this as
30 over 1 and we can cross multiply on
the diagonal so this is the cross
product property so 30 times N equals
360 times 1 which is 360 and if we
divide both sides by 30 n comes out to
12 so you could say this is a 12 God or
this is also called a dodecagon okay
dodecagon decagon is 10 sides dodecagon
12 and then number 6 here it says name
the regular polygon that has an interior
angle of 170 now sometimes I like to
change up the problem a little bit like
if we know the interior angle is 170 how
much is the exterior angle well just
like we were talking about in a previous
problem they're supplementary the
interior angle the exterior angle which
means that the exterior angle would be
10 and we can use this formula just like
we did in this last problem but in this
case I'm going to use this formula right
here the measure of an interior angle so
it's n minus 2 times 180 divided by the
number of interior angles equals the
measure of one of those interior angles
now what we can do is we can also do the
cross product so 170 N equals 180 times
n minus 2 because anything times 1 is
itself let's distribute the 180 so that
comes out to 180 and minus 360 equals
170 N let's subtract the 180 n that will
give us negative 10 N equals negative
360 and if we divide by negative 10 and
comes out to 36 so that means that this
is a 36 God meaning has 36 sides or 36
angles if you want to see more examples
follow me over to that video right there
where we dive into some more examples
similar these so you can get some more
practice I'll see over in that video